hello and welcome to this video playing
is chic not right about this probably 85
so Queen's Gambit okay what am I going
to play man let's go for this one
remove the CAPTCHA Oh Queen b6 hmm don't
quite know what's best
do you go c5 they immediately are play
Knight c3 first don't know okay let's go
c5
yeah this structure with there with a
double pawn it's usually believed to be
a bit better for Wyatt let's see I can
play b5 now immediately I think yeah I
mean it looks like slow development but
I think simply achieving this some
justification it look justification
enough so here yeah I have to go back so
this whole structure now he is extremely
favorable if I get the second before b5
in so let's see if I go III and night h5
I would really like to keep this piece
yeah
[Music]
okay so he tries to trade this probably
successfully do I need to spend any time
on developing this Bishop before b5 is
what I want to do
okay now I'm threatening simply to Brep
on a sick sent yeah but this is this is
like this is just extremely nice for
white okay 90 X is more yes and probably
also just correct still I have not
developed the kingside and this is
[Music]
something to to check okay so he's got
b6
I've got no development there 96 Rogaine
is the thing
but he has b6 on the cards
I should not fall asleep but it's also
important and maybe rooks see one so
that I can actually push c6 after b6
okay
that took ages
that's something that I probably could
have played a lot quicker if I would
have thought about this a bit more and a
bit more of a methodical way like yeah
what what does black want to do and b6
we need to be ready about this ready for
this and here b-66 looks okay I think
even though I mean if I would just have
like two Tempe like Bishop b2 and
castles it was it would just be game
over like this it's not not that simple
actually because of the sluggish
development it's got rock a tomb
[Music]
I need to just he makes some moves
quickly and my time is dwindled Windell
Dawei in a very very extreme way
I think I'm very okay I just just spent
ages on those on those moves earlier and
that can can cost me on nine seconds
well I was a very stupid move by the way
Bishop si - oh shoot I know and I'm just
about not losing material which is
extremely lucky I mean very inconvenient
to play the same
[Music]
may I can ask Bishop b5 will be my move
isn't that a double attack maybe has to
go back now
my time management in this game was the
absolute worst when management is even
it seemed totally misleading word yeah
like there was some sort of yeses some
sort of method to this madness
absolutely crazy what I did in this game
yeah I cannot cannot take this
yeah it's just going to be very equal
here could often draw and
yeah it was pretty bad because the
position roughly here is excellent for
white but I have just completely fell
asleep yeah I don't know what happened
Brooke c1 is a good move I mean it's a
good move I just like it a lot quicker
and I missed some chances of course
later we kim jae-wook a1 this is good
yeah yeah I've got important resources
that I have okay 3y right mmm
g4 this is the important thing
he's just at the end suffering with this
pawn yeah I was happy that I got
something traded I mean that'd be five
of silly but ever had was like on ten
seconds or so it was quite lucky that I
was not losing material immediately and
if I've now yeah
what's good using the temporarily
misplaced pieces yeah this is this is
getting I just take before and with a
piece yeah well that's what happens
there if you get yourself into those
idiotic time pressure like here I mean
just oh one just wins I mean I saw that
this is clearly better so I just played
it but you can win a piece and the other
way and what I also should have done is
here would be seven
yeah I should of course take with the
rook I was I was simply not I was
overlooking that he can look that he has
kingly aid after support eggs I thought
I could operate with c8 Queen as d8
Queen here this is probably pretty awful
for black now I'm feeling way too much
give me much too much to my opponent so
that's a game that should never end in a
draw already okay guys thanks for
watching